depuis que son village a été placé en
crise sécheresse Céline Gavinet a dû
changer ses plans pour l'été
en été on met une piscine ici juste là
grande piscine puisque les enfants sont
relativement grands piscines assez haute
d'un mètre 20 et ben là il y en aura pas
cette année du fait déjà de l'arrêter
préfectoral
interdiction de remplir les piscines
interdiction d'arroser avec de l'eau du
robinet les potagers entre 9h et 20h
interdiction également d'irriguer les
massifs de fleurs de la commune une
grande partie de l'Eure-et-Loir est
placée en crise sécheresse alors
capucine you a trouvé une solution pour
sauver son jardin elle a investi dans un
récupérateur d'eau de pluie
un vrai gros orage ça remplit tout d'un
coup je peux arroser tout le jardin
pendant une grosse semaine avec deux
récupérateurs de 300 litres dans le
village cet agriculteur lui aussi s'est
adapté à cette situation de crise
matthieu mardelet a changé son type de
culture
notamment en maïs et en betterave au
profit des cultures légumières telles
que mes pommes de terre j'ai des aussi
des haricots verts des petits pois de
conserve
et des oignons Mathieu mardelet peut
encore arroser ses cultures mais dans le
département les agriculteurs sont
inquiets et craignent des restrictions
d'eau les rivières commençant à être en
crise on risque d'avoir des jours de
coupure dans les jours qui viennent une
journée ou deux par semaine les plantes
risquent de peiner peut-être un petit
peu plus mais voilà ça c'est une
adaptation qui faudra faire pour les
agriculteurs Iran on heure et Loire
l'hiver a été anormalement sec et les
nappes phréatiques sont à un niveau très
bas